it's International Women's Day how the
stars are celebrating plus one of
Oprah's cardinal rules that Reese
Witherspoon broke and we're also with
Queen Kris Jenner let's go girls happy
International Women's Day I gotta say I
was raised by powerful women grew up
around them and work alongside some
pretty badass women too so today we
celebrate you what better way to
celebrate them with some wisdom from my
biggest source of in spoke Oprah
I mean she's filled with it and she's
spilling more sage advice for us as
Gwyneth Paltrow's first guest ever on
the GUP podcast don't hold anything too
tightly just wish for it want it let it
come from the intention of real truth
for you and then let it go and if it's
supposed to be yours it will show up and
it won't show up until you stop holding
it so tightly I mean y'all hear that
write that down if it's supposed to be
yours it will show up alright lady oh
also unveiled a relationship rule keep
your personal life private you're
thinking what can we say this week
that's going to sell some stories it's
also why I stopped making as many public
appearances with Stedman because I
realized that every time there's a new
photograph there's a new story
it's an invitation it's an invitation
yeah you got that too right yeah took me
a minute I guess so Oprah has one other
cardinal rule and it's don't you gum in
front of her well apparently her wrinkle
and time co-star Reese Witherspoon was
not build in and broke her rule one day
I walked on the set and I was like I
stink I'm cuz I had like coffee breath
or something then I was like hey what's
up Oh bro are you excited bout this name
she's like are you chewing gum
and I was like yeah she's like no one
she was gum around me like nobody gave
me the rules noted Rhys was not only
confronted about this on The Late Show
with Stephen Colbert but she also got to
meet her Olympic King and America's
Sweetheart Adam rip on and it was
everything you probably imagined
[Applause]
it's meant to be okay this is the
relationship the world has been waiting
for yes
lay off my man Reese all right how
fitting that we're actually talking
about Reese Witherspoon one of the
leading voices in the times up movement
today on International Women's Day Reese
commemorated the day at the UN where she
spoke about women's rights and time's up
other stars flocked to social media
today with special shoutouts to women
and among them Jane Fonda who tweeted to
the trailblazing women who came before
me and the many young women who are
taking the torch and running with it
thank you Shonda Rhimes wrote today we
celebrate women rising up around the
world supporting each other and pushing
for change now a woman who knows a thing
or two about raising powerful badass
women is Kris Jenner
he caught up with the grand momager as
she celebrated dr. Paul Nassif's opening
in Beverly Hills we talked to her about
everything that's going on with her
famous daughters starting with pregnant
Khloe we got a lot of stuff today it was
a really productive day and Khloe's
really excited and setting up two
nurseries one in Cleveland and one in
Los Angeles so it was great fun running
around picking stuff out Chris also gave
an update on new mom Kylie who gave
birth to her daughter stormy last month
she's doing really good she's happy
everybody's healthy thrilled as for
Kendall Chris says she's doing well a
source told ET the model was briefly
hospitalized over the weekend before
attending the Vanity Fair Oscar party
Sunday night she didn't feel good and
then she was feeling a little bit better
so she went to the party but she looked
great she had fun our guys for more with
Chris head over to ET online.com slash
daily Deni by the way today is day one
of my vegan diet so wish me luck I need
the recipes hit me in the comment
section but also ET hit 1 million
subscribers to our YouTube channel which
is absolutely insane we're working on
something special for you guys but in
the meantime thank you so much for
watching and liking and for subscribing
we totally owe you
but now go tell your friends about us
alright love you guys bye Danny
yeah